you ready yep
thumb
index
middle finger somewhere over here
almost almost okay closing
our sense of touch is important because
it's how we interact with our
environment it keeps us safe for example
by letting us know if something has
pricked us or if it's at a temperature
that might hurt us your sense of touch
also provides important clues for
navigating the world so what if you lost
it either partially or completely we're
going to explore how brain computer
interfaces and other technologies are
helping paralyzed and partially
paralyzed patients not only restore
their ability to move but also their
ability to feel the world around them
this is sense makers today we're talking
about touch
[Music]
this feels kind of cold on the outside
is it ice cream so how was my brain
processing that information
well sensory cells in your skin send
information to sensory neurons in the
dorsal roots of the spinal cord from
there that's relayed up to the brain
your brain and spinal cord process these
signals and with another set of neurons
called corticospinal neurons it sends
response signals to different parts of
your body this happens in fractions of a
second giving us immediate feedback or
feeling but what if for some reason
those neurons are damaged and that relay
system is either compromised or breaks
down a couple of years ago sharon law dc
was in a car accident and it wasn't
until two days after then that's when i
said well i can't move my thumb so i'm
getting out of this accident thinking oh
wow i just i lucked out big time little
did i know what was really
happening what was happening was a
peripheral nerve injury compromising the
ability of signals to go from her brain
to her left hand and back and it wasn't
just her ability to move that was gone
the feeling was gone it freaked me out
that tactile information helps your
brain make tiny adjustments you might
not even notice but that are critical
for handling everyday objects like a pen
cup or i sense i have flat edge flat
edge and as i come up here i'm i'm
sensing that it's it's fitting on either
properly or it's not lining up at all
can you do it with your eyes closed
these days
uh you know what let's try it see now
this is threaded wrong i could tell
i have it on the crooked it's not there
yet
hey guys
[Laughter]
that was good that was the first that
was absolutely yeah you look really
happy because you know
little things like this make my day in
the two years after her car accident
sharon went to more than a dozen doctors
who told her she'd never regained
movement and feeling in her left hand
now i've asked my son to tie the shoes
i've asked these guys to tie the shoes
i've asked the people in the stores to
tie them it's it's a little
demeaning and now i'm to the point takes
me a little longer but i can double tie
them and that means independence she
found help at the feinstein institutes
for medical research outside new york
city it's one of several organizations
around the globe that are trying to help
patients move and feel normally again
and the key to her success is this
sharon is getting hooked up to a device
that taps into her nervous system it's
what helped her feel again
what is that so this is a patch of
electrodes so we're actually trying to
stimulate and electrically modulate the
spinal cord the dorsal roots those are
the roots that pick up sensory
information chad bouton is the vice
president for advanced engineering and
he has been working on developing brain
computer interfaces and other
therapeutic technologies since 2005. we
use a very intense but short pulse it
lasts less than a thousandths of a
second
but we also repeat that about 50 times a
second and that starts to activate the
circuits the tiny electrical zaps that
this machine sends into share and spinal
cord help awaken and reconnect some of
the neural circuits that were damaged
that didn't happen overnight it took
sharon coming into the lab for more than
30 sessions each one lasting hours but
now her strength and sense of touch have
improved so much she can do things like
catch a ball and drive see this feeling
of being able to do this is like it's
incredible all without needing to get
hooked up each week and because the
year-long treatment worked for her chad
thinks that bodes well for people with
similar injuries there's hundreds of
millions of folks that have had a
peripheral injury much more than the
more severe cases of spinal cord and
brain injury and so yes that opens up
avenues to help a large number of folks
others with more severe injuries like a
spinal cord tear might not be so lucky
often these patients have completely
lost their ability to move and feel for
them brain implants will be key these
devices don't snap onto the back of the
neck instead they require surgery to
place them directly on the brain
before he started working with sharon
chad was part of a team that used a
brain implant to help a quadriplegic man
move his hand again one comment that he
made to me one day was that he was
thankful for the movement that he was
doing but he couldn't feel any of the
objects that he was interacting with
traditionally brain implants have
targeted the motor cortex which controls
movement not the neighboring sensory
cortex which processes information about
touch chad is leading a clinical trial
that recently started enrolling patients
who will get five brain implants to
target both their motor and sensory
areas the system is called neurotouch
and the chips which are made by
blackrock neurotech look like this three
will go into the sensory cortex the aim
is to restore both movement and the
sense of touch but that requires more
than just these chips it also hinges on
complex algorithms that decode neural
activity and then turn those signals
into movement and sensation part of the
neurotouch tech are pressure sensors
that wrap around a patient's fingers a
computer translates that information
into signals or electrical activity the
brain can understand and then we
stimulate the sensory of the brain and
that person who normally can't feel
anything in their head will now feel
some sensation and tingling in that
fingers why doesn't every paralyzed
patient have a brain implant
already there's a cost factor you know
these technologies are very expensive
still at this stage another big hurdle
is that researchers still don't fully
understand how the brain encodes sensory
information we were just at the point
where we're trying to understand the
language you know just at a basic level
that means that even when they're able
to elicit sensation it may not feel
entirely natural the more brain activity
neuroscientists are able to record the
better ai will get at understanding how
the brain works in other words the
future success of brain computer
interfaces will hinge on an intimate
collaboration between us and machines
and in some ways that can help us regain
part of what makes us human
being able to connect with the world
around us and with loved ones through
touch it's not just an issue of physical
health our sense of touch is also really
important for our mental health that's
what drew me to the census to begin with
their ability to stir emotions and make
our lives richer so now that we know
more about how technologists are trying
to restore our sense of touch tune in
next time when we explore another one of
our critical senses
you